my buddy steve this is my buddy josh yo
man you can have anything we got a great
barbecue man every year we got this dope
dude i want to do a special i'm doing
one out the bathroom
it's going to be prolific the eddie
murphy 80s voice
man i'm going to whoop your ass down i
don't need money you'll better give
money yeah you should do that now
it's maybe try it out uh yeah and i go
uh
i um i tried they just kind of rejected
me he goes ah [ __ ] him hey hey i want to
talk to you man i love your stage
presence man yeah wow oh man it's
[ __ ] great but your [ __ ] is
crazy jack
i don't give a [ __ ] god damn
look at you what are you obi-wan kenobi
he was just he just kept saying you bug
me look at you your eager face
yeah
yo what the [ __ ] are you wearing yes
[ __ ]
yes yo sucker jacket get up pick it up
hey pick it up ah there's a girl i went
out for a girl oh yeah that's a stupid
guthrie i just want to tell you guys man
i really enjoy your very talented boy
i'm [ __ ] finished
hey excuse me we don't need to
explain that to us
yo i heard you were talking to my girl
listen bro one more time you're cruising
for a bruising
i just i understand what you're saying
wow this guy's doing the whole body i'm
very good podcast the best podcast
i'll be doing it once a month because
i'm not a loser